Last time we were discussing
the rationality of suicide.
We separated the question of the
rationality of suicide from the ethics of
suicide,
of the morality of suicide will be
turning to the morality of suicide later
today,
but the first question,
thinking about the rationality of suicide
was whether or not it could actually
be the case that somebody would be
better off dead. Having argued that,
at least on what struck me is
the more plausible theories.
That was a possibility.
We then turn to the question of under
what circumstances more particularly or
perhaps a better way to put it,
at what point would it be true that
suicide might be rational in tackling the
question? We were initially bracketing
the question about whether you could ever
reasonably or rationally judge that
the circumstances actually obtained.
We'll turn to that question a few minutes.
The question we were
focusing on originally,
it was just from the objective
perspective as it were.
What does the graph need to look like in
order for it to be the case that you'd
be better off dead and suicide
would be a rational choice?
I do a variety of different graphs and
different different lines about your life
doing better or worse and noted for
each one of them. At what point,
if ever suicide might
be a reasonable choice.
Why to draw a couple of more grafts
before handing this bit of the discussion.
So the, the easy your call, the axes, the,
the x axis represents time.
The y axis represents how good or bad
your life is overall taking into account
the value of being a life per se.
If you accept a valuable container theory,
the higher the line, the better your
life is at that time. The lower the line,
the worst your life is at that time.
Might say the easy cases,
at least from a philosophical point of
view, are ones where things get worse.
Eventually your life
becomes worse than nothing.
You'd be better off dead and it's going
to stay that way until such time as you
might die from natural causes
dying from natural causes.
In a situation like this,
killing yourself from here
on out would make sense.
Assuming you knew the facts could trust
your judgment and so forth and so on.
Some of the issues that will
come back to in a minute
and indeed as we saw,
there'll be even cases in which it might
make sense to kill yourself earlier if
this was the last chance at which you
had the ability to kill yourself or not,
even though you'd be giving up
some life that was worth living.
That was the only way to avoid a much
larger chunk of life that was not worth
living, so suicide might
makes sense. The other hand,
if the choice was way back here,
although this is killing yourself early
on would be the only way to avoid the
later chunk,
not worth living at least
if that chunks small enough.
I suppose it was like this,
we'd say doesn't make sense
to kill yourself this early.
It'd be throwing away too much even though
that's the only way to avoid the bad
stuff.
Now as you say,
that's the easy graph where you go from
a life worth living to a life not worth
living in stays there,
but to Paul's instead.
We have a situation like this
here, life becomes worse
than nothing for a while,
but you recover.
You're going to return to a life that's
worth having and suppose that you,
after you recover,
you'll have a very nice third stage,
third act of your life before you would
eventually die of natural causes or
natural death.
Here are the crucial point to make of
course is that even though for a while
your life will be worse than
nothing negative overall.
It doesn't mean that it makes sense to
kill yourself at this point because of
course, although it's true that
if you do kill yourself here,
you're avoiding this negative chunk,
this bit below the x axis.
Doing that also throws away the very
large third act where your life returns to
being better than nothing.
Since the choices have
neither of these or both,
and the positive third act is great
enough to outweigh the negative second act
on bounced, it doesn't
make sense. But of course,
so even though your life might be
worse than nothing, for some stretch,
suicide wouldn't necessarily
be a rational decision,
but it's crucial in making that argument
that the what I've been calling the
third act,
here's one,
here's act to here's act three is crucial
in making this argument is that the
third act was sufficiently great,
sufficiently long and sufficiently high
that it outweighs the bad of the second
act. And although that's true,
the way I've drawn the graph,
we could imagine that it
wasn't quite like that.
Suppose that
after the second act in which
your life is not worth living,
you will recover and have
a third act in which life,
once again is good for you.
Overall.
Still at this point at three doesn't
outweigh act two although those are
recovery,
it's too short,
not high enough to outweigh
the bad of that too.
And so under that circumstance,
when you ask yourself,
let's say at this moment, you know,
would suicide here be rational?
The answer could well be yes.
Although killing yourself,
you've given up act three which would
be good for you overall doing that.
The only way to avoid act two,
which is bad for you overall
and sufficiently bad to
outweigh the good of act
three. So if you've got the
choice and suicide here,
it might well be
rational. Notice, however,
that's a crucial point again,
is when are we talking about the
possibility of committing suicide?
Committed suicide here might be rational,
but not necessarily indeed not
at all at this later moment
because at this point, the
fact that you've gone through
act two is now history.
There's nothing you can do about it.
You've had this horrible period
of your life and now it's over.
Your question is not can you avoid
act two it's too late for that.
You're a simple,
you're asking yourself,
what do I think about act three should
I avoid act three and that doesn't make
sense. We've stipulated that act
three is good for you overall,
so here suicide no longer makes sense
even though it would've made sense over
here.
The interesting point is that these
possibilities and our mirror theoretical
possibilities but actually can happen.
There's a famous case of in the,
in the bioethics literature of somebody
who suffered a horrible set of burns
over great deal of their body
and had to go through a period,
a very long period of recovery
in which they were hospitalized,
basically immobilized and in a great deal
of pain while their nerves regenerate
it and their skin we graft and the like.
And early on in that period,
this person said,
although he believed that
he eventually recover
what he was going to have to go through
was so horrible that he wished he were
dead because of the nature
of his hospitalization.
He wasn't able to kill himself.
He asked that he be killed and people
refused and he went through a period and
sure enough, he recovered and
eventually he said, yes, no,
my life is worth living again.
And of course,
since it is worth living,
now that I'm able to kill myself,
it no longer makes sense for me to kill
myself because here I am as he might put
it in act three with the life
we're living. But for all of that,
even though I now have
a life worth living,
I haven't changed my opinion.
That would have been
better for me back here.
It's toward the beginning of act two
for me to have been killed or for me to
have died.
It remains the case that I wish I had
died here so as to avoid all the pain and
suffering even though I'm now in
a period which is better for me.
Good for me overall. All
right. One other case,
this is just repeating a point
that actually made very early on.
Okay.
In all of these cases where I've
argued for the rationality of suicide,
it's because of then surely the
line his dipped below the x axis.
The crucial point to remember is
even if your situation deteriorates
and indeed doesn't recover,
that still doesn't make suicide rational.
The question is not am I worse off than
I had been or then I might have been had
I not had the decline?
The question and thinking about
the rationality of suicide is,
am I so badly off that
I'm better off dead?
And if your life is a sufficiently
rich and valuable one,
there's a great deal
of room for going down,
having a worse life while still ending
up at a life better than nothing.
And in that case,
of course suicide's not
rational at all still,
it does seem to me that there are cases
in which the line does cut below the x
axis and remained there for
a sufficiently long time.
Perhaps remain there forever so
that the person is better off dead.
And so we might say
from that point of you,
if only the person could recognize the
facts and know for a certainty that's
what their line was going to look like,
suicide would at certain
points be rational
still.
That means we need to turn to
the second part of the question.
Somebody who believes suicide,
it cannot be rational, might say, look,
the whole game is in the
phrase I just used. Sure.
There are situations in which
if only you knew the facts,
if only you had a crystal ball.
And knew for a certainty this is what my
life is going to go on from here on out.
Then suicide would be rational, but of
course we never have a crystal ball.
We never have the guarantee that
this is how the line's going to go.
The question we need to turn to now is
could it be rational for you to judge
that your situation is one in which the
line's going to go below unstable or
stable long enough so that
unbalanced you'd be better off dead.
Let's suppose that somebody situation
is like that or at least the can be
situations like that.
Could it ever be reasonable to judge that
your situation is like that and if so,
could it ever then be reasonable to
act on that judgment and end your life?
We still bracketing questions
about morality here.
We're still looking at things from
the personal, rational perspective
and once again, what I want to do
next is distinguished two questions.
They want to distinguish between questions
about what should we say if you were
thinking clearly versus what should
we say if you're thinking is clouded.
Again,
one might think,
look in the type of cases where
suicide might be rationally warranted,
it's going to be so stressful that
nobody can think clearly in the middle of
that situation and so even if it were
true that you could reasonably decide to
commit suicide, if only you
weren't thinking clearly,
nobody does think clearly.
Let's come back to that worry in a moment.
Let's assume for the moment that you
can think clearly about your situation.
Perhaps you've got some
sort of painful disease,
but the disease is not painful constantly.
There are periods in which it comes to
an end brief periods in which you're able
to assess your situation,
weigh up the facts.
Could it ever be rational in that
situation to decide to kill yourself?
Well,
as they say, we don't have a crystal
ball. If he did have a crystal ball,
if you knew for a certainty that your
line was so bad that it was below zero and
wasn't going to recover,
perhaps we'd say, yeah,
in that case it would be
rational to commit suicide,
but we don't have a crystal ball.
What should we say?
Then the critics of suicide
might come back and say,
well, look, since you
don't have a crystal ball,
since you never know for
sure that you won't recover,
since there's always a
possibility of recovery,
suicide never makes sense.
After all,
we all know that there is
constant progress in in medicine.
People are always making breakthroughs
and what seems like an incurable disease
one day may have some
sort of cure the next,
but if you've killed yourself,
you've thrown away any
chance of getting that cure,
and even if medical
cures don't come around,
okay,
various diseases sometimes simply
have miraculous remissions.
Somebody might just get
better spontaneously.
That's always a possibility.
It doesn't happen very often, but it
does happen now. And then and again,
if you've killed yourself,
you've thrown away any chance of recovery.
So the critics of suicide might say,
given that there's a chance,
however small of recovery,
whether through medical progress or
just some sort of medical miracle,
okay,
but of course if you kill yourself,
there's no chance of recovery given
that it doesn't make any sense.
It can't make sense
rationally to kill yourself.
That sort of position gets
articulated now and again,
but I think it's got to be mistaken.
It's true that we don't
have a crystal ball.
And so in deciding
whether to kill yourself,
what you're doing is playing the odds.
You're gambling.
But still gambling is something
we do all the time. Indeed,
there is no getting away from the
fact that in the suicide case,
in the case of some
terminally ill patient,
or at least somebody who
appears to be terminally ill,
there is no getting away from the fact
that regardless of what decision he or
she makes, they are gambling, gambling,
playing.
The odds just is one of the facts
of life about how we have to decide.
We have to make our
decisions under uncertainty.
That's suppose somebody says, well, look,
since we agree that we're
deciding under uncertainty,
it doesn't make sense to throw
away the small chance of recovery,
and then I want to say that doesn't seem
to be in keeping with the rules that we
would normally use in
deciding how to face a gamble.
The back of this room,
there are two doors,
so let's talk a little fantasy science
fiction story about the two doors.
After class is over,
you're going to have to decide which
one of these doors to go through.
Let's suppose,
okay
that if you go through door one,
it's virtually guaranteed that what will
happen is you'll be kidnapped and your
kidnappers will then torture you for
a week after which perhaps you'll be
released
virtually certain 90% certain 99% certain,
perhaps 99.9% certain.
There's a small chance one in 1,001 in
10,000 that you won't be kidnapped and
tortured.
Instead,
you'll be whisked away to a
wonderful tropical vacation. Well,
you'll have a fantastic time for a week.
Not very likely,
but not impossible.
One of the thousand one
in 10,000 maybe less.
That's if you go through door one door
one has 99.99 chance of a week of torture
and a 0.01 or zero zero one whatever
it is per cent chance of wonderful
vacation.
If it had,
if you go through door number 200%
certainty that the following is going to
happen,
you will immediately fall asleep.
You'll be in a deep dreamless for the
week. At which point you'll wake up
well, what should you
do? What should you pick?
It's not quite certainty of being
tortured versus certainty of sleeping.
If it was certainty of being tortured
versus certainty or sleeping,
I suppose we'd all agree.
The thing to do is to go
through door number two sleeps.
Nothing positive, but on the
other hand it's nothing negative.
I suppose if we were going
to slap a number on it,
we'd give it a zero but torture.
It's clearly a negative and
if it's a week of torture,
it's a very large negative,
so it's zero versus some huge negative
number. Certainty versus certainty.
What should you pick?
We'd all agree.
I presume you should pick door number
two and pick the dreamless sleep for a
week.
Now we remember all by weight,
but it wasn't a surgeon that you were
going to be tortured. It was just very,
very, very likely that you are going to
be tortured and imagine somebody says,
Oh, you must go for the
gold. Go for door number one.
Sure. It's overwhelmingly likely
that you're going to be tortured,
but those are very small chance that
you'll get this wonderful vacation.
Whereas if you pick door number two,
you're throwing that chance away.
And so the only rational decision
must be to pick door number one,
hold out for that chance no matter how
small of getting that fantastic vacation.
That's the only rational decision.
If anybody were to say that,
I'd laugh at them. I'd say,
look, if you want to talk about,
well maybe there's room for choice.
Either way.
It depends how great the vacation
is. Something like that. Yeah,
there's maybe room for talk.
But if you want to insist that the only
rational decision must be to hold out
for the chance of a wonderful vacation,
no matter how small,
the odds given that if you don't
get that wonderful vacation,
you're going to be tortured.
And you could avoid all that
by picking the sleep option.
If somebody insisted in
the face of all that,
that the only rational decision
is to go through the door,
which is likely to be torture and a
vanishingly small chance of vacation,
I'd say they are just wrong.
That's not a rationally required
decision given the odds.
Yes.
Question
bias,
it's not a temporary state doesn't last
forever,
so it makes more sense for you.
But we actually choose what's your,
um,
great. So, so the question was
this, so the, the, the quiet,
the point was perhaps I'm cheating in
making the example this way because death
of course isn't of course what you're
all supposed to be lulled into.
Thinking is that death,
choosing death,
choosing suicide is sort of
like choosing to be asleep.
I stayed in dreamless sleep,
but sleep nonetheless.
And the suggestion that was I'm
cheating because death is forever.
I deliberately framed the example in
terms of being tortured for a week versus
being asleep for a week and
perhaps given that choice,
it's clearly rationally acceptable to
decide that you'd rather pick the sleep
for a week option,
but death isn't just for a week.
If you commit suicide,
you're dead forever.
So let's change the example.
Suppose that you know you guys are mostly,
I suppose in the vicinity of 20 suppose
that if you go through door number one,
there's overwhelmingly likely chance
90% 99% 99.9% chance that you'll be
kidnapped and tortured and the torture
will take place and last for another 50
60 70 years and then you die.
There's a slight chance
a 10th of a percent,
a hundred of a percent that no, no, you
won't be tortured for the 50 60 70 years,
but instead you'll be brought to
this tropical island paradise.
We will have this great
time for the next 50 years.
But what has happened in 99 out of 100
cases or 109 hundred 99 out of a thousand
cases or 9,999 out of 10,000
cases is the torture scenario.
While the people are being tortured,
they beg for mercy,
they begged to be put to death.
They wish they were dead.
It is truly the case that the tortures
are so bad that these people are better
off dead.
Remember,
we're assuming that we've got a case
where you really will be better off dead
and less than miraculous recovery
takes place. And so again,
we have to ask in a situation like that
where the person says if you and I,
and similarly of course if you
go through door number two,
you immediately fall asleep and you stay
that way for the next 70 years and then
you die while in your coma.
The fan of door number one comes along
and insists the only rational decision is
to pick door number one
where it's overwhelmingly
likely that you face 50 years
or 60 years or 70 years of torture
because of course if you were to pick door
number two,
you're throwing away your chance no
matter how small you're throwing away,
the only chance you have of
the wonderful vacation, well,
each of us has to decide for themselves.
But when I think about this case,
this modified case,
I still want to say choosing door
number two could perfectly be,
it could be a perfectly rational decision.
It's just not right to say.
The only rational decision
is door number one.
Yeah.
Again,
somebody wanted to take a more modest
position and say it depends on how great
the vacation would be,
how mild the torture would be.
Maybe 1% chances versus a 5% chance.
There's room for debate about when might
the the balance come closer to even.
So it would be reasonable to take the
chance. Yeah, there's room for debate,
but if it, chances are small enough
and the person insists nonetheless,
no matter how small the chances are,
it could never be rational
to pick door number two.
I can only say that doesn't seem to be
the way we would normally think about
making choices,
and of course at this point you can see
how the argument exactly carries over to
suicide.
If you kill yourself,
you're throwing away forever
any chance of recovery,
and that's important and
that's worth thinking about.
But it's also important to think
about what was the chance of recovery,
how large or more to the point,
just how small and how badly off will
you be if you don't commit to aside,
you guys are 20 but of course these sorts
of choices also perhaps get faced by
people who are considerably older.
I now in the final stages
of some progressive disease,
the doctors told them perhaps there's
70 that there's no significant chance of
recovery.
Sometimes it happens,
but no more than one in a hundred or
one in a thousand but if you continue
alive, you will be in,
well, perhaps great pain.
Perhaps unable to do the various things
that give your life meaning and value.
Could it be true that it
would never be rational,
provided that you're thinking
clearly, never rational to say, look,
the chances of something negative are
so overwhelmingly great that even though
deciding for death throws away whatever
small chance I've got of recovery,
the chance of recovery is
so small that I'm balanced.
It's reasonable to throw that chance
away and avoid the overwhelmingly likely
possibility that I'll continue
in my current state with
a life not worth living.
Seems to me that you're thinking clearly
there could be cases in which suicide
would be a rational choice.
Yeah,
but that still leaves us
with the question, well,
maybe that's where all
the work needs to be done.
What about this point
about thinking clearly?
Even if we grant for the sake of argument
that there could be cases in which the
person's life is so bad that they
actually are better off dead and they stay
that way.
Even if we grant that,
if only somebody were thinking clearly,
they would see that that was
so likely to be the case,
that suicide would be a
rational or reasonable choice.
Still,
isn't it plausible to think that in real
life people can't think clearly about
their situation when they're
in situations like that? Okay.
It's one thing for us to be
sitting here in this classroom.
Well,
I certainly hope that none of you
are in this kind of situation.
It's easy for us to be
sitting here thinking clearly
about it and recognize the
philosophical possibility of thinking
clearly about a case and realizing that it
was a rational decision to
end it and end your life,
but people who are actually
in those situations in point
of fact are not able to
think clearly because just think about it.
What would have to be true of you for
your life to be so bad that suicide might
be a rational choice?
That you'd be better off dead?
Yeah.
Odds are you've got to be in
some indeed more than just some.
You've got to be in a great deal of pain.
Probably a great deal of physical pain.
Beyond that,
you probably also need to be incapacitated
in a certain large number of ways so
that perhaps you're bedridden.
Can't enjoy discussions with your family,
can't read poetry or watch
television or whatever it is,
a life watching television may not be as
fantastic as the like that you all are
able to have,
but it might still be better than
nothing to imagine a life so bad.
It's going to have to have so much
physical disability that the amount of
emotional distress is going
to have to be so overwhelming.
How could anybody think clearly
in a situation like that?
Okay,
and then the argument might go,
he can't think clearly.
You can't rationally decide
to trust the judgement.
You might make that you're in a situation
where suicide is a reasonable choice.
You might make the judgment,
but if we ask ourselves,
should you trust your opinion,
the odds are so the argument goes,
no, you shouldn't trust your opinion.
Precisely because anybody for whom
it would be true would have to be so
emotionally distressed that they're not
able to think clearly if they're not
able to think clearly.
They can't have a judgment
that's trustworthy.
The judgments not trustworthy,
you shouldn't trust it.
And so suicide could never turn out
to be a rational opinion after all.
Well,
that's an interesting argument.
I think it's an argument more worth taking
seriously. And some of the other ones,
some of the early objections we've
had against suicide, but even here,
I'm not convinced.
Let's again try to think of a case not
quite like suicide and ask ourselves,
can't there be cases where despite the
fact that you're thinking is clouded,
it's still reasonable to
trust the decisions that you
make within your cloud or
thinking?
Suppose you've got some
disease that causes you a
great deal of incapacity and a
great deal of pain,
but as it happens,
there's a cure,
or at least there's a surgical procedure
that can be done and the surgical
procedure is almost always successful.
So what are the choices?
Choice number one,
continue in your current state.
You've got some horrible painful disease
and it won't get better
unless you have the surgery.
If you do have the surgery, it's very,
very likely that it will get better.
99 cases out of a hundred the surgery
works or 99.9 cases out of 100 there's
surgery works are 99.99 cases out
of a hundred the surgery works,
of course, like all
surgery, there are risks.
Sometimes you put the person under
anesthesia and they don't wake up.
Doesn't happen very often. One in 1,001
in 10,001 in 100,000 whatever it is,
there's some chance to surgery won't work
and you'll die on the operating table,
but it's very,
very small chance.
Overwhelmingly likely the surgery will
succeed and if it does succeed, oh,
you'll be recovered. That's option
number one. Option number two,
you continue in your current state,
incapacitated or unable
to lead a valuable life,
suffering full of pain.
Well,
that's overwhelmingly likely
one in a thousand cases,
there's some sort of natural cure.
Maybe one in 10,000 cases
there's a natural cure,
but in 999 out of a thousand cases
or 9,999 out of 10,000 cases,
the disease just continues
until till you die.
Some years down the road
there's your choice.
Should you have this surgery or not?
I suppose what we think is of
course you should have this surgery.
You'd be a fool not to have the surgery.
It's overwhelmingly likely going
to cure you, but now we worry,
wait a minute,
can you trust that judgment after all
the condition you are in is so stressful,
so painful that you are obviously Neary
emotionally worked up and any judgment
that you make that it's a
reasonable decision to have.
The surgery is a judgment.
You're while under the
cloud of emotional distress,
how can you possibly trust that judgment?
And so you shouldn't trust the judgment.
The argument goes and so you must never
agree to the surgery in this situation,
but that can't be right.
Yeah,
surely we agree and it couldn't be
reasonable to trust your judgment in this
situation.
Now to be sure the fact that you are in
all this pain shouldn't make you pause,
should make you hesitate,
should make you think twice and then
think again before deciding what to do.
But still, if somebody says,
since you're so worked up,
it could never be rational to
decide to have the surgery.
That just seems to be going too far.
It doesn't make sense.
You got to make some kind of decision.
Deciding not to have the surgery is still
making a kind of decision and either
decision then is a judgment that you're
going to be making wild worked up while
stressed while under the
cloud of pain and suffering.
So think twice.
Think third time.
Get the opinions of others perhaps.
But still,
if somebody says it could never be
rational to decide to have the surgery and
then act on that decision,
they're just wrong.
Well now let's come back
to the suicide case.
Same kinds of odds just reversed.
If you don't decide to commit suicide,
we are imagining that it's overwhelmingly
likely you'll continue in suffering.
Some slight chance that you'll recover,
but overwhelmingly likely you'll can,
can continue in suffering.
Whereas if you do kill yourself,
it's overwhelmingly likely,
perhaps even guaranteed your software,
you will come to an end
only chanted it won't is if you think
there's some chance of an afterlife.
Well,
should we be swayed by the argument at
this point that since you are suffering,
your judgment is cloudy and so you
should not trust your judgment?
Well,
that can't be a good argument.
If it wasn't a good argument
in the surgery case,
I can't see how it could suddenly become
a good argument in the suicide case.
What does seem writers,
precisely because you're working and
deciding under the cloud of emotional
stress and pain that you should think
twice and think a third time and perhaps
think yet again, you should not
make this decision in haste.
You should discuss it with your doctors.
You should discuss it with
your loved ones, but if says,
you could never reasonably trust the
judgment that you make while in the
circumstances,
I can only say that doesn't seem
like a sound piece of advice.
That claim doesn't seem right to me.
I conclude therefore,
that as long as we're focused on the
question of the rationality of suicide,
ethics aside,
the rationality of suicide
under certain circumstances,
suicide could be rationally justified.
You could have a life that
is worse than nothing.
You could have good reason to
believe you were in that situation.
You could either be thinking clearly
about your situation or even if your
judgment is clouded and difficult,
you could still find the odd sufficiently
great that it was a reasonable to
eventually trust your judgment.
The rationality of suicide
I think is secured,
but for all that,
of course it could still be immoral.
There couldn't be actions that
are rationally legitimate,
but for all that morally illegitimate.
As I mentioned previously,
there's a big debate in philosophy as
to whether or not these two things can
really come apart or not.
Arguably,
reason actually requires you to obey
morality and and so even if something's in
your self interest, perhaps it's not
rational to do it if it's immoral.
Interesting question.
Let's just bracket that question and just
focus directly on the question now of
morality. What should we say
about the morality of suicide?
Rationality aside, what should we
say about the morality of suicide?
Well,
to really do justice to this question,
of course we would need to have an
entire theory of morality lay down and
unsurprisingly I don't have time
to do that for us. You know,
entire class on introduction to ethics
where we try to lay down a basic
fundamental theory about morality.
All we've got left as a couple of
minutes today and then one more lecture.
So instead what I want to do is first
mentioned some quick and dirty arguments
that had a kind of moral tinge to them
and then turn to some somewhat more
systematic arguments where I'll quickly
put in place some basic elements of a
plausible moral theory. We won't
have time to explore them in detail,
but at least we'll get a shape of a basic
moral theory and see what it might say
about suicide.
So systematic a little bit later.
First some quick and dirty arguments,
whether we should call it a moral
argument. The first one or not,
I'm not quite certain,
but it's certainly an argument that
gets stated all the time in this area.
When we think about the
legitimacy of suicide,
yeah,
it's common enough to have the reaction.
Suicide is illegitimate because
it's thwarting gods will.
Maybe this isn't so much a moral argument
as a theological argument and for the
most part of course,
as you know in this class I've avoided,
okay.
At least some theological questions is
obviously question about the existence of
a soul as itself.
I feel logical argument,
but I've tried to discuss them as far as
possible without bringing in questions
about God.
God's existence in God's will,
but the topics almost unavoidable.
When we think about suicide,
given the prevalence of the thought,
it's God's will that we stay alive and
so it's going against God's will to kill
ourselves.
Well,
I think the best response to this argument
was given by David Hume some several
centuries ago, two and a half
centuries ago were Hume says, look,
yeah,
if all we've got to go on is just the
idea of a creator who has built us and
given us life,
we can't infer that suicide
is against God's will.
At least if you found that
thought a compelling one,
then why wouldn't you also
find it compelling to say
it goes against God's will
when you saved somebody's life is a point
that close to one I've raised before.
You're,
you're walking along chapel street and
you're the person you're talking to.
You see he's about to be hit by a car,
so you push them out of the way.
Previously when we talked
about this question,
the question was whether or not
they should be grateful to you.
Now the question is whether or not they
should complain. How dare you do that?
You've sorted God's will.
It was God's will that
I be hit by that truck.
So when we're about to
save somebody's life,
should we decide not to do that on the
grounds that it must be God's will,
that they're going to die if you're a
doctor and somebody in cardiac arrest and
you could now perform CPR or whatever
it is in order to get their heart going
again. Shouldn't we say as a
doctor, oh no, I must not do that.
It's God's will that they die
if I try to save their life,
I'm forwarding God's will.
Well, nobody says that,
but then
why is the argument any better?
In the case of suicide,
we could of course,
imagine you know when,
when you're,
when you've saved your friend's life and
he says, Oh, you forward and God's will.
What? You might come back
and say, oh no, no. You see,
it was God's will that I save your life.
Yeah.
And so it was God's will that you be in
this situation where the truck was going
to hit you unless I saved you. But it was
also God's will that I save your life.
And maybe the doctors should
say something similar,
not an implausible thing to say,
but given that that's not
an implausible thing to say.
Why not say the same thing about suicide?
It was God's will that I be in
this situation and then God's will.
Did I kill myself
absent any special
instruction manual from God?
The gods will argument cuts both ways,
which is to say it doesn't
give us any guidance.
We don't know whether it's God's
will that we act or God's will,
that we don't act absent an
instruction manual from God,
so we can't conclude that suicide is
obviously wrong because it violates God's
will. Well, unless you've
got an instruction manual,
you might think, for
example, that you know,
the Bible tells us not to commit suicide,
and since the Bible is God's word,
we must do whatever the Bible tells us.
That's a kind of argument that I'm
perfectly prepared to engage in.
Although of course there's a lot of
assumptions behind that argument that we
would need to really examine.
Yep. Is there a god? Well, the,
obviously we needed that one
even for the gods will argument.
Has God expressed his will in a book?
If so,
what book is it?
Do we have more reason to obey God?
Also relevant for the gods will argument,
and of course if we do think we have
an obligation to obey this instruction
manual,
are we really prepared to
obey this instruction manual?
Even if there's a sentence in
this instruction manual that says,
don't commit suicide?
A lot of other things,
the instruction manual also says that
most of us are not inclined to do.
Instruction. Manual says
not to eat pork. Oh,
how many of you are not
willing to eat pork?
The instruction manual tells you not to
mix various kinds of material together
in a single item of clothing. How many
of you think that that's unacceptable?
The instruction manual tells you that
if a teenager is rude to their parents,
they shouldn't be stoned to death.
How many of you think that
that's a moral requirement?
If you're going to pick and choose
which bits of the instruction manual you
actually think are morally irrelevant,
then you can't come to me and say, oh,
suicide is wrong because the
instruction manual says so.
You're not really using the instruction
manual to give you moral guidance.
You're starting with your moral beliefs
and then picking and choosing which bits
of the instruction manual you want to
accept. Well, that's a big question.
That's a big topic and so
having just touched on it,
I'm going to have to put it aside.
Instruction manual aside,
at the very least we might say,
appeal to God's will can help us to decide
whether or not suicide is legitimate
or not.
There's a different quick
and dirty argument also,
it can be run in a theological forum,
but it need not be run that way
and that has to do with gratitude.
We've been given life on.
Life's pretty amazing,
and so we have an obligation,
a debt of gratitude to keep the gift.
Now,
look,
gratitude is not one of the moral virtues
that gets a lot of discussion nowadays.
It's fallen on rather hard times,
but I see no reason to dismiss it.
It does seem to me there's such a thing
as a debt of gratitude is someone does
you a favor,
you owe them something,
you owe them a debt of gratitude. And
so the argument might then go, look,
either God gave us life or nature gave
us life or our parents gave us life.
Whatever it was.
We owe a debt of gratitude for
this wonderful gift and as such,
how do you repay the debt?
You repay the debt by keeping the gift.
If you kill yourself,
you're rejecting the gift that's being
ungrateful and in gratitude is immoral.
It's wrong,
and that's why suicides suicide is wrong.
That's the second quick
and dirty argument.
Perhaps it won't surprise you that I
don't find this second argument persuasive
either. Not because I'm skeptical
about debts of gratitude,
but I want us to pay attention to what
exactly obligations of gratitude require
us to do.
In particular,
it's important to bear in mind that you
owe the person who gives you a gift,
something only when what he's given
you or she's giving you is a gift.
Okay?
Imagine that somebody,
I'll call him the bully,
gives you a pie and says,
eat it.
It's not an apple pie.
It's not a cherry pie.
It's some Gross,
disgusting slicing Pie,
some rotting slime pie.
And he cuts out a big piece and he says,
eat it.
Do you owe this person as a debt
of gratitude out of gratitude?
Do you owe him the obligation to eat
the pie and continue eating the pie?
That would seem like a
rather odd thing to claim.
This guy is indeed as I've named him,
just a bully.
Now, of course, typical bullies, at least
you know in the, in the comic book cases,
bullies are big and strong.
The bullying might be able to
say the following thing to you,
you eat this pie or I will beat
you up or beat the crap out of you.
And, and, and look, I'm
not a very strong guy.
He might well be able to do it
and I might not. I might. Well,
no,
he is going to do it.
And so it might be prudent
for me to eat this lime pie.
Disgusting, appalling, as it may be.
It might be better to have a couple
of slices of slime pie than B,
three beaten up to a pulp,
but there's no moral obligation here.
There's no moral
requirement to eat the pie.
Well,
if God takes on the
role of bully and says,
eat the pie,
or I'll send you to hell,
maybe it would be prudent to
review to do what he says.
And if God takes on the
role of bullying and says,
even though your life has become so
horrible that you'd be better off dead,
I insist that you keep living or I'll
send you to hell if you kill yourself.
Maybe it's prudent of
you not to kill yourself,
but there's no moral requirement here.
God's just a bully on this story.
Now,
that's not to say that
I think God is a bully.
If you believe plausibly enough,
God is good,
then God's not going to want
you to continue eating the pie.
Once it's spoiled, he gives
you an apple pie. He says,
eat it. It's good for you. You'll
like it out of gratitude. You eat it.
But then God not being a bully
says if the pie ever spoils,
you can stop eating.
Why in the world would he insists that
we continue to eat a spoiled pie if he's
not a bully?
So I can't see how any argument from
gratitude is going to get off the ground.
If there's something
immoral about suicide,
we're not going to get the immorality
through these quick and dirty arguments.
We're going to have to get it from some
more systematic appeal to moral theory,
and that's what will turn to next time.